on today's visual studio toolbox our Rob
is going to show us how to build a gr PC
service from scratch hi welcome to
visual studio toolbox I'm your host
Robert Greene and joining me today is so
Rob sure howdy welcome to the show
thanks Rob no I'm happy to be here and
we're gonna talk about gr PC that's
right you've been on you're on on dotnet
talking about it you've been on cloud
native talking about it's my turn to get
you on my show to talk about it but
we're gonna take a slightly different
approach we are gonna talk about what it
is but I want to approach it from the
angle less about the underlying
technology and plumbing and more from
I'm a visual studio developer I've been
building services for a long time I've
built WCF services I've built Web API
services now this looks like a new way
to build services why what does it do
why what are its advantages and then
what should i do should I convert my
existing services and then how do you
actually build one because so far the
only demos I've seen the service has
already been built and it turns out I
did not know this until recently and in
20 minutes all of our viewers are gonna
know this - did you can actually do this
inside Visual Studio file new project
created G RPC service that's right cool
that's what we gonna do so what is it
why was it invented so GRP see is an RPC
framework and for as at least long as
I've been alive people have been trying
to make computers talk to each other and
invoke methods on some other computer it
lends itself well to distributed systems
things like that you can it is a
requirement to scalar effectively so
your PC comes from this project I was
internally developed at Google called
stubby stubby right and your PC is the
rewrite / public version of it so we
chose to build your PC support like
first-class your PC support in dotnet
because it's one of the most popularly
used RPC technologies today
one of the key things to keep in mind is
when you are talking with other machines
and other computers not only do you want
a rich and robust ecosystem for your
language of choice you also want to be
able to interoperate between other
language stacks right so while we could
have picked something like say WCF which
is limited to the dotnet ecosystem like
good luck getting that to work with a
micro service or it didn't go running in
kubernetes right so the the benefit of
Jura PC is it's it's like a
fundamentally good protocol as well as
its popular and adopted by many other
languages okay so does it lend itself to
one type of service versus another so I
could think of a service that you know
you build a Web API or restful service
to return the weather or you know the
time I enter a city and I get the time
back or a lot of WCF services were
written to do crud support for databases
right select insert update delete what
if I'm doing those types of services
when I when I use G RPC for those so
Ghibli sees a low-level protocol so it
doesn't lend itself better to say you
know weather updates then crud
applications for lob like that fix it's
a lends itself well to both there are
four fundamental types of calls you can
do at your PC you have unary calls which
would be I send a request as a client I
get a back a single response we have
both server and client streaming so I
can send as many requests as I want then
get back one final response from the
server or on the flip side I can send an
initial request and get back multiple
responses from the server and also
support for for bi-directional streaming
so with those primitives you can pretty
much build most applications okay so you
could do the just get the single value
back
or the crud but it's more potentially
more optimized for these other scenarios
is that a true statement I I would
hesitate to say that I would say it
depends on your like domain and what
your application does okay like if I
want the weather and the weather is good
for about an hour there's no point in me
asking for it every 10 seconds right no
matter how good the streaming protocol
is so do what's best for your
application okay but if you want to call
a service that tells you number of
people that have walked through the door
right like I want a service that tells
me when the stadium's half full and
there's people streaming in literally
he's streaming in right it would be
perfect for something like that right
like a use case okay all right cool
let's build one all right so I'm gonna
hop over to visual studio I'm actually
using your computer so yeah there's no
hacks to move that to prove that there
are no tricks behind the scenes this is
not an internal build this is my machine
running public latest version of Visual
Studio so we ship your PC templates in
the box
all right and so we've gone ahead
I picture PC mm-hmm I'm just gonna
what's called it Geo PC service for tool
box okay I hit the name Bert just to
disambiguate so you see the Jo PC demo
so this actually the Visual Studio new
project dialog discovers templates
installed by the dart and SDK the ships
is part of the SDK even though today
we're focusing on the visual studio
support and how to do it yeah if you
were using a Mac like I do then you'd be
able to do the same thing I'll be it
from the command line
okay and you could put it in a container
I see yeah so let's just keep it so now
keeps it but that's not good to know and
it said something about supporting
dotnet core right so the GOP see
library that they're the Jaypee slamming
that we're talking about here is jpc
dotnet there's actually another
implementation of GR pc for dotnet this
is one of the original libraries
authored by a couple folks at Google
while they both work we're going to be
focusing on your PC dotnet because we
think that's the more refined experience
however this limit is limited or darknet
core 3 o and above so keep that in mind
if you want some interoperability maybe
you need some xamarin support you may be
forced to take a look at those other
libraries ok some of the tooling that
I'm gonna show you works in regardless
of which your PC library you use it may
provide you in the direction of using
libraries we think are better but you
know some of these pieces will work ok
cool so let's see so right off the bat
if you're familiar with asp.net core you
would recognize this is an ASP nightcore
application we have you know startup see
us programs yes it looks like a regular
ASP in an application
I do want to bring your attention to
this directory here called proto's right
so in here we have a file called greet
dot proto so this is a prote above file
what is a protobuf so protobuf for is
short for protocol buffers it's the
ideal the interface definition language
used for GPC so it defines the service
yes it's expecting what it's going to
return exactly ok so as you can see let
me highlight an area of interest that's
the actual service definition with the
our pcs this is a unity RPC call so
single requesting all response and you
can see it's defined in terms of message
types you also see that the message type
definitions are contained here ok so see
the way you start with the GPC services
you probably first author your interface
definition right once you do that you
want to hook it up into msbuild
and say hey use this to connect stubs
that i can use to go write a service or
client right so on the service you get
these service stubs that you can fill
out the implementation for on the client
you get a full functional client that
you can go and invoke calls on so once
we have authored this file well we go
ahead and do is I'm gonna get your
attention to this menu we're going to
right click on my project I clicked add
and this an option called service
reference right so you can see that this
document is already reference it says
hey this was grid proto it said
reference to a document and the type of
chord generation was a server because in
this project I'm implementing the the
service side of it right what we'll do
after this is go in plant a client as
well that actually invokes the service
implemented by this right and then
points to the location you could you
could easily go point it create another
you know create a new profile and hook
it up and if if you know this is the
pretty UI over it if we actually drop
down to the project file you can
actually see what's happening so we're
actually linking to this directory proto
slash v dot proto and we're saying
generate service yeah so you can
generate only the message types server
client or both okay so once we've done
all that let's actually go look at our
startup so our program remains pretty
much unchanged we got a start up you'll
see a couple of things you will see in
configure services I make a call to add
your PC okay you need to do that and
then the other thing in my configure
method was I'm actually building my apt
funk out in my endpoint routing I have
this endpoints our Maps your PC right we
we don't we haven't done any reflection
II magic like we do in the case of MVC
where we do controller discovery we've
suggested that you create a directory
called services and put your service
implementation in there okay but that's
just a convention but what you do need
to do is actually register each of these
services in your application
and then speaking in this like I've
obviously registered so I do want to
point out one more thing you do not see
any path or URL because GOP see is an
opinionated protocol so based on myself
so as I've been the keys to being
opinionated but I don't think it's the
same thing i I think it tries to take a
lot of ceremony away from you and in a
lot of scenarios that's extremely
helpful because it makes you more
productive quickly like when I map this
in I didn't have to think about what's
the path on which it's gonna be served
right what's the path pace how I
communicate that or client as long as
the client knows that this is where my
gr PC endpoint exists everything else
has like built into the protocol okay
so let's go in and actually look at this
service definition oh shoot ah oh sorry
I realize you didn't have function
Locker
oh okay so so now we're in the the
actual service implemented reader
service okay so one thing you will
notice right off the bat is this greeter
base mm-hmm so there's some of this
magic that we skipped over but when you
did the entire gesture in Visual Studio
to add service reference to a profile
and Austin to generate stuff mm-hmm it
actually did some magic and generated
stuff so this actually lives in my
object folder I can go over into this
but this is generated code yeah so not
only do I have generated code for the
service I also have it for the message
so it also contains code on how to
serialize deserialize messages right so
when I come over my experience is a
developer is I go into I go to my
service definition and I can just you
know override the RPC methods that I
want let me show you an example of if I
hop back over here let's do this
I'm gonna create another RPC let's call
it say hello to so we don't have any
conflicts all I did is I hit save right
now we have the design time build and
visual studio happening under the covers
when I save so if I come back over into
this file I'm gonna go do you see this I
do there it is so yeah I get say hello
to and it you know I already have the
other right so that was the integrated
design time build experience in visual
studio that allows you to be super
productive when you're like quickly and
it knew to do the task hello reply for
you you didn't have to type
yeah I didn't have to type that sweet so
that's some fun stuff we did
so now after having looked at all this
code the thing you'd be curious just
good is how do I run this right mm-hm I
see what's going on so I'm just going to
go ahead and run this project so this is
also a point for us to sanity check make
sure I didn't like click around and mess
something up see you ran by I just hit
f5 ok cuz I noticed there wasn't a run
button right so okay if you look at the
logging again very similar to what we
see in XP 9 core says now listening on
localhost 5001 okay so let me copy that
and is it safe to use this press it is
safe to use edge yes it is language okay
so if you can't read what it says here
oh well good news is it talked to it
yeah it says communication with your PC
and finds must beat me at your PC client
which makes sense right I open it in the
browser but this isn't web app right but
because we were built on top of asp net
core it's just a friendly thing we put
it in the templates to warn you so for
folks were trying this I would highly
implore you actually go to setup view
link what we'll doing the rest of videos
walk through how click like creating a
client looks like
but for folks hanging it at home that
like the the tutorials are up to date
and they should follow that call all
right
so so now that we have this running and
we've established that we need a juror
PC client let's actually go through the
experience of creating a new project
adding in a client and then me so there
is a run button
yeah okay so my solution I'll add a new
project we don't need it to do anything
fancy so I'm just gonna add a console
ooh
nearly clicked on that VB there for a
second okay okay so so far everything's
good now we're gonna make use of that
service reference experience that I
spoke about cuz they're just a service
and you want to reference it so and
service reference cuz it's in the same
solution it should know about it no so
you have to explicitly point ah okay so
I have to point to the proto file I just
want to show you one thing before I
click on this you see there's also URL
so if you're you know company publishes
your profiles at a central location or
you're taking a dependence on somebody
else's service like you have a micro
service team and you need to call
somebody else service yeah you can
actually point at a URL and this studio
will keep the URL handy and then you can
refresh it if need be okay so I'm
actually gonna point so we got a walk up
this directory and then in the proto's
directory so again this is a convention
based if you want you can move it as a
solution item then both the project
excuse me utilize yeah why not add that
and then remember I mentioned you can do
any of these since we're going to use
this as a client let's actually go ahead
and generate a client so so we need a
couple of packages so the tooling is
intelligent it's it adds the service
reference as well as brings in the
package dependency so it says this is
good let's actually go ahead and look at
the CS brats to see what exactly
happened so you can see in broaden
google protobuf GOP scene that client
factory injuries
tools okay so this is everything that we
need to actually make make the line call
okay so shall we go ahead and write some
cord do a sure okay so the first thing
we need is a channel so think of channel
is the underlying connection so I'm
gonna I'm using the using bar syntax
because it's really nice and I believe
we have static helper method that hangs
off of oops
it's always hard getting used to
somebody else's keyboard okay so I might
not have gone into great detail but the
I know these services listening on
localhost 5001 at least that's what we
configured it dude right so let's do
that and now once we have a channel we
can new up a client and give it the
channel so I will do
oops and now we pass it the channel
mm-hmm and now once we have a channel we
can actually let me show you what hangs
off the channel so we can actually
involve Malia like hello acing you see a
hella way I think do as well because
we've added it to the profile yeah
obviously it's not implemented and then
let's just go look at this method
definition right what do we have to boss
the hell away sync we need to pass it a
request right
it needs a hello request okay and that
was we go back to our message file just
to remind ourselves
hello request just took a name so I'm
gonna jump back over to my cord before I
do that I'll do
oops it's not finding hello requests
yeah you know let's do Robert if I can
spell your name
alright and then I should just be able
to do it call make this call this
actually is anything I mean we generate
both the synchronous and asynchronous
methods it's the recommendation that you
do this so it's probably going to look
like oops I that also means you know I
can use the semicolon in yes c-sharp is
at age seven point two has a sink main
so that makes oops yeah yeah the
challenges of using someone else's
machine alright and well that's why I
gave you a mouse talking someone who
uses a Mac and you know I'm just gonna
put it now oops
console dot read key at the end it just
doesn't close on all right ok so things
look good to me you can go ahead and
build all right so let me go ahead and
so this should start debugging the
service mm-hmm right now we also want to
launch the client so let me go into the
client
oh right here you should see the quest
finished executed end point great leader
say hello this is also thing I was
talking about it like how the the URLs
are convention based yeah so its package
name service name and then RPC method I
don't have to you know figure it all
that outlets work for me the other thing
which won't be like worth looking at is
this is reminding ourselves right we're
actually calling a method from one
application into another one right and
we're we're able to call it as if it
were in the same thing that's the the
goal of RPC if you will so I can
actually go ahead and you know maybe say
put a breakpoint in here as well as put
a breakpoint in my service just to show
you what that feels like
right so I go ahead and run this again
and let me debug this as well if you're
doing more development you can use
Visual Studio and said multiple startup
projects this is just since we did a
couple of executions so you can see I
hit the breakpoint on my client yep if I
hit continue you should see now to hit
the break by myself all right so it's a
it's a you know nice experience for
developing services so you know and then
now that this is perfect it's been
tested rigorously we're ready to go we
just publish it to Azure and we move on
right
there are certain challenges there ah so
while jpc builds on existing
technologies like protobuf and http2 it
actually uses let's say the full gamut
of features supported by HTTP to
something that not all HTTP 2
implementations support today and which
means if you're running anywhere in a
hosted service where you go through a
proxy or something like that
you really need to make sure that
everyone up into that point supports
full fidelity HTTP 2 intend so we're
currently working closely with the azure
team you know we hope to get there soon
but it is a change because it requires a
change to the kernel more needs to be
driver in Windows like HTTP sis and then
we have to work our way up the stack ok
so I think takeaway for people is we're
working on it but it is a big project
and I can tell you and it'll be done all
right mmm fair enough but you can deploy
it the azure kubernetes service right ok
it's just not not as your app service
because they have some proxying going on
in front for you ok great so we
accomplished what we wanted to
accomplish we reviewed what G RPC is
talked a little bit about some of the
scenarios and then most importantly saw
that right now you can build one from
file new project in Visual Studio
awesome I do want to show one more thing
because you have that voice like what
about to wrap up so that is my we're
about to wrap up voice 5 I
go over to the docks and point out that
we have docks for remote procedure call
app so this has a full introduction and
tutorials it covers a lot of things you
know practices patterns things like that
so please check out the extensive
documentation I'm so and will put a link
to that in the show notes
thanks so much all right thank you hope
you guys enjoyed that and people should
try these out start experimenting with
them get used to them because this is
this is coming this is here and this
will get more and more power I mean you
did say coming but these are production
quality libraries they've been shipping
is with an on preview monocle
since three oh so they're about like
more than six months in again alright so
this is here this is a viable option
people check it out thanks and we will
see you next time on visual studio
toolbox
[Music]